what's happening you Savages it's
Tuesday the 17th of October the checkin
is brought to you by come on manscape
listen they've leveled up and so should
you they launched the fifth generation
performance package including the all
new lawnmower 5.0 Ultra listen I've
already got mine plugged in I haven't
done the the honors yet but the 5.0
features two interchangeable blad heads
with three length settin Combs
waterproofing you get any look anywhere
you can design stuff it's all over
that's it you can have a party in that
shower it's waterproof now the
performance package 5.0 also features
the new weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose
hair trimmer and the crop preserver ball
deodorant which is [__] Wala you know
what I'm saying it's tremendous in the
summer you'll be rocking worlds in the
winter the crop Soo the Tona and two
free mystery gifts so do me a favor
Uncle Joey's giving you 20% off and free
shipping with code Joey Jo OE y
manscape.com
again that's 20% off in free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com your
balls have been through enough trust me
I looked at mine the other day what a
nightmare you thought Vietnam look bad
it's it's time to go Ultra with mancate
support the show and get 20% off and
free shipping when you use code Joey and
now that you're all trimmed up and ready
to go Uncle Joey's gonna drop it on you
with blue chw listen you never know when
you're going to meet that special
someone if you want to make sure you
have all the confidence in bed at the
drop of a hat then you need blue Chu
listen it's the season to be jolly
blue Chu is a unique online service that
delivers Ed medicine straight to your
door with the same active ingredients as
Viagra Calis Levitra all that stuff but
at a fraction of the cost and you save
money while having an awesome sex life
and like they said they deliver right to
your door you don't need to be creeping
while they're sleeping you could take
blue at any time of the day and night no
matter when you need that extra boost
blue Chu has your covered listen I'm an
old guy from time to time I get urges I
have desires I pop a blue chw it's all
over but the Sho blue
Chu excuse me blue Chu is done entirely
online so you get to skip the doctor's
offices the awkward conversations and
waiting at the pharmacy it's even
shipped in a totally discret package so
you could stock up without worrying
about the nosy neighbors or the mailman
you know what I'm saying listen blue Cho
wants to help you have a party a real
party for the holidays you know what I'm
talking about discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and then do it Jack
we got a special deal for our listeners
try blue Chu for free Joey why you
busting my chops on the Tuesday free
[__] just pay $5 shipping that's
blue.com promo code Joey to receive your
first month free visit
blue.com for more details all right
without further Ado let's get Lisi at on
the phone turn off your TVs run for your
lives it's over they didn't put you on
this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I could rule the world
that's what you got to be thinking
welcome back
[Music]
to
boom what up Tuesday how's it going
buddy you know looking good feeling good
I smell like a [__] billy goat but I
took a shower before this I took a
shower I took a little nappy Noo-noo I
don't know if I was high and tired I
don't know how many showers are you
taking now what's up with you what I'm
doing how many showers are you taking
now because you would always come in
showered for the podcast two maybe three
like today I really took three because I
went
to so I took a shower you do the whole
thing what you do the whole thing every
time yeah you gotta wash your head
behind you I'm a filthy dude bro you
know I got [__] a yeast infection in
my ear you know I got problems dog I've
been [__] I had to get medication I
had to put some [__] cream in my ear
you know you're [__] 60 I don't know
I'm just trying my best to keep it
together I got a nice head do she put a
little [__] dead ink in
there you know it's keeping together I
got like 13 hairs I drink my collagin
every [__] day what do you drink you
know the the milk that comes out of your
titties when you first have a
child the collagin whatever the [__]
it's are you saying collagen no it's not
collagen
look it up it's called Arma a r m r
a okay I didn't know there was just a
thing yeah look at that what do you
think you're dealing with Joey
bananas why you bothering me Lee I don't
know I'm sorry how was your weekend very
good that's it right there what's it say
I can't read without my glass what's it
called
what is it called I can't read that what
do you mean you can't read it
colum yeah and that helps with hair why
didn't I know about that it's supposed
to fill your hair yeah it does help my
hair but the hair on my kneecaps the
hair on my arms the hair under my
armpits I'm everywhere where I don't
[__] need hair in my nose my eyebrows
I got to trim my eyebrows every four day
at the wolf man's nephew every four days
I got to ask my wife because you got to
put glasses on and try to trim your
eyebrows [__] Houdini can't do that
one you know so you gotta have a partner
or you better pay the barber an extra 10
bucks oh I've never had I have to trim
my ears and my nose but I've never had
to trim my eyebrows yet oh it's coming
[__] it's coming and you don't
even see it till you go to Vegas like
you don't even see nothing until you go
to a different mirror you ever noticed
that you go to a different mirror that
[__] never lies to you your
mirror at home comes your psychological
friend think about this [__] next time
you go on vacation you will at home you
don't see a lot of stuff because you're
so used to your image in that particular
mirror you comb your hair you brush your
teeth you shave whatever right but then
you go to a hotel in Vegas you come out
of the shower there's a mirror right
there and that that's the first time you
look at yourself new in years that's a
[__] confidence burner right there
and then you go to shave or brush your
teeth after the shower forget about it
you see hairs no you see that one long
[__] stranded hair and then you want
to shoot yourself because you got no
nose trimmer and you got two shows the
rest of the weekend it's a [__]
nightmare man have you ever I [__] up
I had to take an Uber in Columbus
because I try not to go I try to shave
my head before shows and the thing BR
and the thing BR it died halfway through
and you look likeo and taxi driver for a
minute there you look like the chubby
guy in The Road Warrior the Lord
humongous I look [__] up I had to ride
in an Uber I lived with you for eight
years I know exactly what you look like
I never had a half a head come back
there I don't know if you DG I feel bad
sometimes I don't even know if you can
wipe your ass correctly because you
can't reach back there you got like bad
shoulders you always leave like a little
patch back back there like a little
afro oh when I was really fat I couldn't
wipe like that it wasn't good thank God
for the
tushy no I'm I'm sure you could wipe I'm
just it's a [__] joke Le I know but
I'm I'm telling you the truth but no I
would F I would like you would kept
saying I would have strips and I would
check and sometimes I would but most of
the time I wouldn't most everyone I hate
I always miss a
spot do I miss a spot you know I when I
shave I don't use a mirror in the shower
I just dope it up with shaving cream and
I go by sound you know Uncle Joey do I
just put make the water hot I make the
pores open up there ain't no mirror
every you always you ever buy those
[__] no fog mirrors that's F that's
for people take showers in cold water
that ain't for people Savages like me I
go in there I turn I turn the knob all
the way to the end it's like I'm going
to the
chair do you really you keep it at the
end oh I push all the way to the end I
like my shower hot I put the heater on
my bathroom is [__] cold in the
mornings so I gotta put heater on before
I go in there I mean the heat goes in
there but for some reason we have a
[__] Sky roof in the bathroom why I
don't know who would sit in the [__]
shower looking out the window like a
[__] idiot you know it's like you
don't do that huh you don't you don't
look out the window no when I go in the
shower I'm focused on washing and
killing the germs and you know I thank
God for giving me another day and I'm
grateful for you and Joe and you know
Mike and all the people I deal with you
know that's what I do in the morning I
get my head together sometimes I get too
stones and I got to turn the water a
little cold you know what I'm saying
yeah the shower can be scary when you're
high that's crazy like but you have
where do you keep the heater like like
heating a heater and like water from the
shower does shower and just play [__]
Fear Factor it's under the sink
[Laughter]
that's what I was worried about [__]
shower with me and take my
chances Oh either I die or come out
glown in the
dark that's [__] up oh my God I had a
pretty good weekend I got to do two
shows on Saturday one at 5 in the
afternoon one at 5 which was listen dog
I didn't want going to say nothing and
[__] burn your parade Dracula don't
come out until the sun comes out Comics
don't go on stage till the sun comes out
all right it was it was an interesting
time but it's a fun room like the guy
who runs it's really cool um but it was
yeah five o'clock was the earliest I've
ever they gotta be home by 7:30 what the
[__] it the start you know those five
o'clock people gotta be churchgoing
people so they were you know what they
were very nice
but but you you're very nice also bring
me with you one time and let me come out
there and go look at you five o'clock
maggots gotta be home by 7:30 to catch 7
AM to prove to these people that you're
a good [__] Christian get the [__]
out of here have a cocktail tell the
baby say to stay home you giv her the
extra 50 you're gonna come up and dress
home like bat whatever the [__] you want
to do that's got to be rough going to
comedy at 5 in the afternoon I hate it I
even like going on stage of seven and
the sun is out yeah it's different it
fathers the [__] out of me and even
though you're inside a dark place I
still know it's [__] light outside
sometimes you're not there there's
Windows you can't you ever been in a
club with Windows I want to do comedy
when it's dark out and you can get
mugged that's I want to do comedy when
half of you're in there because you're
[__] petrified in the streets you're
G to come in there with Uncle Joey in
the security at the comedy club so
nobody bothers you I swear to God these
Edibles I must have had some mushroom
juice left over in my system from the
weekend and these Edibles set these
[__] off I'm seeing things I'm
hearing things what are you
seeing two of years with a little guy
behind you with a [__] with a stick I
don't know what I'm seeing I'm just I'm
seeing things you know what I'm saying
you ever see things but you don't tell
nobody I got the balls to tell people
I'm saying things all right I advise you
leave now or down
911 Jesus Christ how was your what did
you learn what did you not learn you had
the five o'clock show you did well you
called you checked in and then you went
destroyed the 8
o'clock that it was a fun night I got to
feature
unexpectedly the first show I did 10 and
the second show I did 20 good for you Le
yeah I was I was I thought was going to
do like a FIV minute set and it's a
really cool place in Foxboro it's uh
like for like an you know a Booker who
has a lot of clubs and it's uh I got it
a day before which is like at my level
they don't no one calls me two weeks
like only a couple people usually it's
like can you do something tomorrow so
that was exciting and you know it was a
fun night and I thank you like there was
like five people between both shows that
came out from the podcast so that was
very cool it was it was a lot of fun
people loved to see you in the beginning
so they could say I knew you back when
from my conations with you I was
thinking about this the other night
after I spoke to you on Saturday night
my conversations with you really enlight
me to the fact that how much in love you
are with
comedy oh yeah we [__] around and we
make tapes when we call and [__] you
know but we have to be real high on the
same night to make those funny [__]
calls but I've noticed that 80% of our
calls now are basically focused on
Comedy and it's really inspiring to see
and it makes me believe what I've always
believe about Comics starting
out that the best education you get is
in your backyard and working
outward you know like you stay and then
you spread it's like coid when the
[__] guy went skiing and he landed in
Jersey and he [__] up that Bergen
County Town same thing it's it's it's
it's just really weird to see that when
I lived in La along with you we met so
many people that went out there in their
second year and it's ballsy it's ballsy
as [__]
but like I I don't know to get back to
the conversation it's just really
impressive to see how much you're into
it because you and I both know we ran
into a lot of people that I love doing
comedy I want to do this and I want to
do that and a week later you know
they're not doing nothing right two
weeks later we'd see them and they're
not doing what they told us they were
going to do and we talk about it like
wow you know so it's really nice to see
a guy that works as hard as you I
appreciate it but like I learned a lot
like when I met you I had I didn't want
to be on the podcast like I I we we
didn't fight about it but you're like no
you're I had I was just a fan of
standup and like getting to
meet all the comics that I got to meet
on the church I got to be in like in the
room with the top pod top
comedians of like the last 20
years and I I just I've always liked
going to shows I've always I've just
learned so much with that time we had in
La that I
don't I I don't want to be someone who
someone goes to see and said they say oh
he was just with
Joey he wasn't that funny like I I
really because people give me [__] and
that's fine but I I want to actually be
a good comic that's that's my goal like
someone like that people not respect I
don't like that word but like
acknowledge like hey he he's at least
doing comedy like he's actually doing it
you know everybody always thinks
that people could help
you like I'm just G to jump in and make
a call to Warner Brothers and tell them
that you know I I I lived through that
also you know with the longest yard and
Spider-Man it was always this guy called
for you nobody called I went in a room
with 20 gorillas in audition if somebody
which nobody ever did it would just be
my support to go hey he's a good actor
and a good guy or whatever the [__] you
know but nobody ever did that I earned
those roles I earned test roles so and I
always wanted to prove myself also you
got to prove yourself and people got to
see it you have to your attitude has to
be contagious when you're a comic these
Comics go home and they [__] talk
[__] and they get
bitter you know like they get bitter no
you got to be involved you got to [__]
and that's what you're doing you got to
be able to talk to Bill Burr and you got
to be able to talk to fingerless Joe who
does the open mic on Tuesday nights
who's [__] a great writer but he's
missing a finger on stage and he's a
shame of it or whatever you know you're
gonna run into all those people but at
the end of the day 20 years later I
sherish all those [__] things you
know what I'm saying like I'm I'm done
with those memories like I can I can't
tell you year by year but I can tell you
that something inspired me along the way
and you get just got to put great people
around you a couple open micers that are
good people and you create a little
[__] community in Boston and you
don't need to go to La you're getting
more from what you're learning in that
area than what you would get from
rushing to Los Angeles with your nose
wide
open and there something that's like
really
been nice there's people can complain
about a lot of [__] but something that
has been very nice about
comedians has been like how helpful
other because like they've been there's
been many so many Comics who will put in
a good word for me somewhere or ask me
to be on their show and it's just like
you would think there'd be a lot more
hate and there is I'm sure there's a lot
of hate and I'm sure I get because this
I just want to say one quick thing I
aware that like I I totally get shows
that at my level at like year level I
wouldn't have got or shouldn't like
because I do get a little bit of a b of
a bump up in a lot of scenarios so like
that's part of the reason why I work
hard I just wanted
look your resume has The Comedy Store in
Hollywood on it has The Comedy Store La
Hoya that's great zies on it you've
got have on the Improv I got the Wilbur
you brought me to The Wilbur that's
[__] Broadway but like the Wilbur isw
you out in the Wilbur high as [__] balls
of steel you went out there you barely
[__] walked out there like the
penguin you know I mean and somewhere in
a in a comic's mind no matter what level
that takes a lot of that takes a lot of
people respect
you
I remember one show I did there was a
certain open micer I want you to think
no names there was a certain open that
bugged me bugged me bugged me he came to
the show in Vegas I was gonna put him up
and he told me he didn't want to go up
anymore like he just saw it for what it
was and he was packing up and going home
or
whatever I don't know I don't know how I
felt about him after that now he's doing
standup I think I hope but at that time
you have the opportunity of a lifetime
who cares if you're not ready who gives
a [__] that's a lesson for you that's a
lesson for you you know I mean I wasn't
fortunate enough for somebody to take me
to an arena in the beginning or a
theater I didn't do a theater
till I moved to LA maybe and I did uh
some rooms with Paul Rodriguez up in
north and they were like you know
thousand seat theaters I was getting 500
bucks I would do like three theaters in
a weekend with
him and I always bond in those
days you didn't do well theaters I
remember the one
weekend we did a Friday Saturday and a
Sunday Friday ate a bag of dicks
Saturday ate a bag of dicks but Sunday I
went out there and destroyed the room
some guy [__] knocked on my door and
wanted to do blow with me and gave me a
rock to take the go it was
insane it was insane like I bombed for
two nights but then the third night it
was like a [__] explosion they went
for the material and you know things
happened do you remember I mean I don't
know if you remember this but like did
you do anything different like did you
do you remember changing up like your
delivery
or I remember just being [__] angry
that you bombed two nights in a row in
front of a good Booker and in front of
[__] headliner he didn't watch my
shows it didn't matter but still you're
there somebody enough to be there listen
at the time I was doing spots at the
store I was doing uh you know spots at
The Improv at the Laugh Factory and he
called me one night and goes do you want
to go up there and I was like yeah and
I'll never forget like that Sunday I
just went
off I didn't care where the pieces fall
I was already 0
and2 I might as well go down swinging I
wasn't going to get shot down in flames
and go down 0 and three on a Sunday
night in front of a thousand people so I
C the timing maybe it could have been
the timing of the theater it could have
been the lights it could have been that
I got a good night's sleep the night
before could have been a lot of things I
think I wasn't prepared that's number
one but it's so weird
how I always think about this and I want
to cover this with you because you went
from a huge
market uhhuh and you went backwards yeah
and some people would go why don't you
stay there or whatever but you saw how
hard it was to get I think you're
getting more quality stage time here
than you would over in LA right now in
La you'd still be going up in front of a
lot of
comics yeah yeah I'm definitely quantity
Open Mic wise La would be but the
quality as far as like actually having
audiences no
and and getting like because I went
honestly like two steps back because
Boston I Boston has a great scene but
it's smaller than LA and I I've been
I've spent like a year is a year plus in
Worcester and it was it it
was it was but I I got better because
people were really nice and like I
started to open people and cuz I
remember do you remember being afraid of
doing 20
minutes 20 minutes was a hard one for me
to get over I was afraid of doing 20
minutes of Sam triple shows on Tuesday
nights you know you're in there in front
of a full house I'll never forget this
like I was de friends with the guy who
gave you the time and the light and
stuff uhhuh and he would give me the
light dog I wouldn't even I just run the
[__] out of there like w 20 minutes
thank
God yes I have uh I had a ton of anxiety
about 20
minutes it's it's for some reason that
one took me a while to like feel like I
had enough material
for being up there remember you could do
a quick 20 minutes or you could slow 20
minutes it could be a 20 minutes that's
revolved around patience and them into a
groove or you could just be so scared
like I was 90% of the time and I would
just go out there and rush it just to
get it over with just so I get that $100
bill to go home and snore Co I mean
let's you know just to get that 100 to
buy some beers and sit with some people
whatever the [__] it was I always rushed
through my sets and I didn't become
better till I slowed them down and me
slowing them down
was my confidence
building how do you slow an audience
down that takes
years that takes years because no matter
what I tell you once you go to La once
you're ready and you go to
La you're going to bomb a lot in the
beginning because you follow so many
different styles it's not like I'm
following Lee and I get to adjust to
Lee's energy by Friday which is all I
give a [__] about I'm getting the big
envelope I need to be Tip Top by Friday
and
Saturday so I I'll take a beating from
Lee on Wednesday and Thursday I'll
figure him out and by Friday I'll know
how to slip in there and going on stage
at The Comedy Store improv Laugh Factory
one night you follow Dan
Cook what night you follow some Indian
kid I'm not I'm saying and Indian
because they're a little slow paced they
don't know the language that well so
sometimes you got to follow that
somebody who's Russian and they speak a
little slower because they have an
accent comedy's changing comedy's
growing it's not just for white people
anymore you know what I'm saying it's
worldwide now so I remember still going
some where the [__] did I go that I had
a follow really nice oh when I did
danger Fields right this kid was funny
he was an Indian guy he was funny but
his gift was that he was slow paced and
he kept his volume just a little lower
to because from watching him I could see
people leaning in to listen and I'm like
wow this guy had been doing comedy like
23 years he did spots around the city he
said they wouldn't give him like the big
clubs he told me he won a contest in New
York and he had a a day job he's like
some type of chemist some Indian kid you
know but he was very sweet I I I'm sorry
I forgot his name but I remember
learning something that
night because I went up there fast and I
ate dick for the first four
minutes until I remembered the tempo he
had sucked them in he was so good that
he had sucked them in on that slow
methodical I bought the lottery tickets
55 whatever you know
I'm not trying to be cute I'm just
trying to be
honest and it was an
education it really is a [__]
education but you're not going to get
hit with that till you go to LA or you
go to a good open mic where they
rotate you know if you got 10 good
features in Boston and they all go to
the same Open Mic every Monday
night that's good if the guy who's
running the open mics rotates you
obviously if Dane Cook walks in or
somebody local from Boston that's a star
and they get on stage they close the
room but you teach
everybody I can't wait till you think
you're really really really
funny you got a tight 50 minutes and you
book yourself out as a headliner in an a
room and that's a big
education that's a tremendous
education that's completely different
than you've ever seen before in your
[__] life
because you're not really a
headliner you're just learning how to
put blocks first you learn how to do
tens like you're doing right
now then you learn how to do
20s and then you're done with that and
then you write another 20 and then
you're done with that and then you write
another 20 now you got yourself an hour
right you call the booker and go I got
an hour but now you go out and yes
you're going to learn how to do those
three 20 minute bits but you're also
going to learn how to weave it that
takes about a year and a half two years
to learn how to weave that set together
and that's when you become a
headline I want to go back because you
just kind of blew my mind a little bit
with like following someone's energy
because I don't really I have a few
things that I start with but I don't
that's I think that's sometimes why I
have rough
sets can you like talk like how do you
how do you jump in to like someone
else's energy like what if like they
don't do well what if there is no energy
what if there like it's just that's
crazy to think about first of what to
learn about
energies your assignment from now
on is to go out one night I don't care
who the comic is if you have a Thursday
night
off you're going to go to laugh Boston
Providence
somewhere local hey the small
2250 and I want you to watch that comic
I don't give a [__] who he is I don't
give a [__] if he goes up there with a
ukulele you know I don't give a [__]
because every comic has a different
appeal uhuh 45 minutes because he has a
different appeal whether he's a comedian
that is an AA comic and you're not
allowed to
drink so you're doing comic for sober
people that are drinking water and
eating pretzels I've done that show okay
and
sodas you have so many different
variables of comics you have to watch
them all
live see this age is [__] now you know
we got lazy we got really lazy in fact
we got so lazy that something that
benefited me I get mad about I get mad
that
my wife will call me and say hey honey
what are you doing tonight nothing uh my
friend gave us a reservation for two at
a steakhouse and there's a comedy club
two doors down we've never done
that really do you know who the comedian
is well I just looked him up I'm gonna
send you the link to his stand up and
you know right away I go in there prej
judgmental That's The Comedy Store you
don't know who the [__] you're going to
see but to get back to question Lee
energy you got to watch stand up live
watch it once a week not the but don't
show up at the club like hi pay the
[__] 20
bucks you don't want them you want them
to go why'd you pay nah bro I'm I'm here
to watch The Comedy in fact I'm gonna
sit in the back with a pin colada you
won't even know I'm here and you watch
all three Comics you're going to see the
MC
bomb he's going to get clunky with the
announcements which suck but they also
teach you a different muscle which you
won't see till years later you're going
to see a great feature
act but he doesn't really have 45
minutes but what he has is very
controlled and then you're going to see
a headline of that you're either going
to like them or not but you're going to
go home and
write the things you hated and the one
thing you
liked and now you're G to find what
people see that you don't like him you
may not think he's funny because you
watched him on a [__] Netflix
special you didn't catch him Monday
night when you went to New York City at
the comedy cell at
11:30 that's why when you told me you
were going to the Sellar I always bust
people's balls I didn't bust your balls
that night I wanted you to go there and
watch
right right yeah that was was a great
night that it was cuz you're right like
there are like there's a lot of places
but yeah that like that would be one of
the dreams of a place to go and to
see different levels and to see I what I
I'm not going to like energy yet I guess
but what I do what I do find interesting
is like the different levels of laughter
between like that you would get versus
like my best set like just you know like
the levels of laughter like the level
comedian can
give is like something like it was just
crazy to see what com like a comic can
do with like that level of an like just
that amount of people can make the sound
they can make come out of them it's
pretty
cool it's an
art and I'm happy we do this because I
may not be getting on stage but the last
couple years has given me a chance to
reflect you know my next book is going
to be about standup
obviously about you know the questions
the comic wants to know at the third
year mark at the fiveyear Mark no
pressure you don't have to be
anywhere this will be something that's
going to be for
novices the
hobbyist you know I encourage more
hobbyists than
comedy yeah started that were a lot more
hobbyist to be honest with you these
guys were [__] funny
they had good lives they made good money
they were college
educated they had a wife but instead of
playing darts or playing golf or you
know playing fantasy football their time
out was doing comedy and they would come
out like on a Wednesday night to some
bar to pick up 100 bucks and then that
you would see him on a Sunday at a
comedy
club and I appreciated those guys
because there was no [__] from them
at the end of the night they going
home they're going home and they're
gonna do what you do every [__]
day those guys are better commedians
sometimes because there's so more in
touch with what's really going on you
know how people that get up at 8 in the
morning [__] feel at 9:30 at night
absolutely
we stay out till 2: we get up at 9: we
go to [__] deliver whatever Uber Eats
till 1 we smoke some pot with the Indian
kid and then you're [__] you know
writing jokes and then going to [__]
know get back on stage I
mean but it's just so weird I love the
hobbyist so I want to encourage more
hobbyists because I think doing stand up
[__] helps you in every
field I know the first time I did stand
up how I felt I didn't feel like I was
GNA be a Hollywood star I didn't feel
like I was gonna be Charles Bronson I
didn't feel anything I felt that a
different part of my mind that opened
up it really did I
think go ahead I'm sorry no no go ahead
what was your question I was just like
oh to be honest I forgot no it's
it's it's very interesting you know I
forgot too you threw me to the [__]
woles Lee the Edibles are finally I
gotta be honest with you I ate those
Edibles I ate five and I [__] got
sick for a minute there I had to sit
down that's why I drank this [__] Muk
juice this
[__] Prime because I just GR
and got something I sat down I watched
[__] Houston strike out with three
men on with bases loaded and I didn't
feel good I'm like oh my God I'm gonna
have to cancel this I got thz ex
intoxication I poisoned myself but then
I I did a couple bong hits and I'm back
like herpes you know what I'm saying
that was little figment of my
imagination
Jackson when's the last time you puked
for
medibles
when I puked on uh that one street
driving
home we still lived on
cumston oh it's been that long yeah I
was still in my amateur mode of
Edibles I was just eating them till I
[__] got
sick dude those two I passed out on one
of those
200s did I tell you that like the next
day
I the
abx's when was this
maybe a year ago something like that I
took a 200 you woke up you woke up took
a piss and passed out yeah yeah [__]
what happened the next yeah exactly as I
was taking a piss like the next day I
woke up and it never happened before and
I just W like went right down that's
what happens that's that's the power of
ABX Jack you know when you talk talking
about something
about uh like how Edibles used to come
uhhuh it gave me a memory of Me John and
Ralphie going to a dodging game one day
it was [__] 90
degrees Ralphie got these Sensational
tickets but little did he know we were
in the sun Jack oh no and I mean [__]
bacon in the Sun and before Ralph he
picks me up there was a a weed shop next
to Dukes the breakfast joint right and
one music place on the corner there the
the real whis whiskey aogo I think it's
whiskey another mu music venue then it's
Dukes another building then there was a
weed
store and that weed store had a
refrigerator this is way before I met
you Le when you walked in there they had
a refrigerator the size of like a
[__] Snapple refrigerator the pizza
joint right and it was filled with
[__] cakes and brownies and you know
apple turnovers and [__] and nobody
knew nobody went in there and go hi
excuse me what's the milligram on those
[__] no either you bought the cake or
you
didn't and there was sometimes you ate a
piece of cake it didn't get you high so
you ate another piece of cake and you
were [__] done like I still remember
them carrying Silent Bob
Felipe's friend out of the boxing gym
and his feet were dragging because we
didn't know the strength of Edibles back
then this has to
be 2008 2009 we were just eating
[__] we would
just and wherever the pieces fell they
[__] fell but we went to that [__]
Dodger game with a
bag they let Ralphie walk in with the
[__] bag they let bring food in of
cakes and [__] you know so we're
burning Under the Sun and this shit's
starting to melt this [__] 110 degrees
so I forget we [__] eating eating
eating cakes puddings they had
everything [__] chocolate brownies
with coconut on it God knows Lee how
much sugar me and those [__] guys ate
that day and then we couldn't take the
sun no more so we got out of there and
we walked to the car forget it three
sheets to the [__] wind holy [__] and
you have no idea and barfing that
night I didn't bar from the [__]
reefer I barf from all the [__]
sugar oh you think so I it's like when
you get sick from
alcohol think about what you drank the
night before if you were drinking Tahiti
[__] Reds with Hawaiian Punch you're
going down [__] you know how much sugar
is in that [__] Hawaiian
Punch it's not the alcohol that kills
you it's the [__] sugar you're
drinking rum and cokes all [__] night
like Fidel Castro what think what you
think's going to happen you're gonna
wake up feeling Tip Top meoo not even
liquid IV could save you then you got to
do like a real IV and they gotta rub
your feet that's too much [__] sugar
that's crazy that do you know that's why
I drink diet coke and Makers Mark
because one time I went to one of those
cheap I didn't know it was cheap but I
went to like a open bar thing in Vegas
to watch uh like one of the Cormier Jon
Jones fights and I was drinking regular
Coke in Meer Mark and they of course
water the drinks down so like I yeah I
got I've never I felt sick from all the
sugar I've never had like figured that
out before you know I used to go to this
joint in Miami across from improv in
Coconut Grove [__] tremendously there
were frosted drinks M like smoothies but
they had one that was 140 Proof and it
was red there was a red one that I drank
and a brown one looking one it was 140
[__] proof it was red you know how
many times I woke up and the sink was
red and I was ready to call 911 because
I thought I was bleeding
internally but when you wake up you have
a headache for two days and it's not to
the [__] 140 because I was burning it
off with cocaine this is the
[__] the sugar it was the sugar from
those smoothie drinks and [__] so you
live and you [__] learn but that's
why getting to the original Point that's
why I like ABX Edibles at the end of the
day I'm not eating 3,000 calories they
allow me to eat 3,000 calories later but
if I got to ingest 3,000 calories to get
high I don't want to be a part of that
organization right ABS no ABX are the
best when people come to me I go listen
this is why Tom talk about it I I've K
people with those things oh except for
you you're my brother you know I love
you I never killed you with those things
but no never I I I definitely didn't
have a hotel five minutes down the road
but ended up sleeping at your house who
cares it happens you were tired
sometimes I don't want to drive
either you know I'm a lot happier this
week oh okay well you know they [__]
said I uh I got the [__] whatever the
[__] in my lung so they put me on
the antibiotics and some other [__] to
clean me out it's a two we treatment
with the
antibiotics so I feel better but I'll
tell you what I did Le I for those eight
weeks I was getting you know for like
six weeks I was getting these
palpitations my backs were hurting I
just had so many mental it was just
mental [__] so I continued working out
and walking and hitting the bag but I
stopped going to Jiu-Jitsu because you
gotta walk upstairs to get there and
then when you're there like I I have a
hard time as it is I was like I don't
want to have a heart attack and I'm a
fat [__] and they gonna carry me down
those stairs because a you could have 20
Jiu-Jitsu guys they they're gonna pick
me up and hold me down those stairs at
some point they're just gonna drop me
and I'm gonna roll down the stairs like
a fat [__] with a Jiu-Jitsu G on I need
that um TMZ so I was like do you think
this is gonna happen because man that
you know I know how much I know how hard
I work in that class and how I feel when
I leave there and I know that sometimes
I do [__] in there that I have to get up
and take a walk and pee because I I go
there to you know stay healthy there's a
bunch of young guys there I still keep
them intirely you know at my age
Jiu-Jitsu is completely different you're
not looking to [__] submit you're
just looking to stay alive roll around
but you have to do it perfectly because
if I go in on a Monday like yesterday
and I become king kong then I'm not
going to make it on Wednesday so on
Mondays I just drilled now and I took
one of the younger guys and we did some
situational stuff you know I was there I
took my little whoop watch went up to
[__] 10 so I'm happy that gives me
the rest of the week I got an option to
live today or to go back to class and at
least I lived another day so the next
time I go to class I'll focus on
Drilling and I'll roll little more and
then Friday I'll roll because I got the
weekend to recover so it becomes
something else I got to [__] go to
red light therapy and sweat my balls off
the other day I looked down and under my
nut sack there was a little puddle like
a a little like a little inch like this
pudle and it was it was direct sweat
from my nut juice I think that must have
been like a coating of fat around my
nuts and red light therapy just burned
it off I looked down I was tempted to
pick it up and sniff it like azy and the
Molly Crew movie but I was like let's
leave let's leave byon we by gon I swe
[__] I do yoga in there I do I
breathe I stretch I sit for the F it's
34 minutes at 151 or something right
really
yeah and is it something you lay in how
does it work how do you do yoga in it or
is it a room it's it's a [__] private
little steam bath okay and it's not
really a steam bath it's red light
therapy but you're in there so long that
you [__] start sweating your balls
off so when I first off let's get the
party started right I go in there
early sometimes I go late but I'll try
to go in there like when I say early it
opens at 9ine I'll get there like 10:30
10:15 because I do 34 minutes and it
lets me to come home take a shower put
my gon and go to Jiu-Jitsu it opens up
your breathing but before I do anything
I [__] go in that backyard and I do
like [__] eight bongs ba boom right
off the bat like a soldier right let me
tell you a quick story so yesterday I'm
in the backyard it's like 5 in the
afternoon and I'm just blasting [__]
bongs the big freeze pipe the good
freeze pipe I show you in fact I got to
rotate it my lungs are getting used to
that one I got to use a different design
to blow them back into limbo so I'm out
there and I'm doing these bong hits but
I notice [__] when I blow the smoke out
the wind is taking it and it's really
spreading out right and I must have done
like three of those hits in a row where
you're killing the same [__] chamber
and it was one big cloud of smoke and
there's some dude walking his dog like
a like a like a 66 year old d walking
his dog and uh he's walking like you
know he's he's thinking about Lawrence
wel music he's thinking about you know
1950 when he
was and all of a sudden he saw the cloud
of smok Le and he held on to his dog and
then he looked around and he saw me in
the yard under the [__] thing where
you can see out but you can't see in and
I'm out there doing bongs and he's
looking so he's looking at something
black and he seing smoke come
out wait are you blowing some more smoke
at him while he's still there oh my God
I'm trying to scare this guy to call
like1 and I swear to God he looked like
twice and then he walked by and as he
was walking by I popped up like a like
a and I was like hey how you doing he
just [__]
by all right so Thursday night I did
something that I you
know my friends call me you know what
I'm saying they want to do stuff but I
got to put the pie together because
Thursday night is movie night at my
house like this Thursday we're GNA see
the Dao whatever movie it's me my
daughter and my wife we're gonna sit
there three [__] hours so after
tonight I won't eat no Edibles after
tonight
to huh to prepare yeah three hours in
the movie theater you even need couple
couple Edibles or a left hook that's a
long time you haven't really get to
developing that
[__]
so I uh last Thursday night I planned
there was no movie to go see I'm not
going to see no [__] Taylor rip movie
my daughter don't want to see it you
know my wife don't want to see it so we
got saved from going to the movies so
last week I planned with a couple of my
old school buddies Sharps kti and my
friend Theo to me
at my other Budd he's a manager at this
restaurant in hackins set called fores
Le [__] delicious oh yeah old school
in there they had a lot of dishes that I
wanted to
try but I only eat you know I had a cup
and a half of pasta pul with some
Italian bread and then I had a piece of
lasagna that was so good but yet again
so [__]
Rich [__] delicious and I think the
off the owner said to me very nice
people the owners cuz my buddy's the
general manager whatever the [__] he
does in there my buddy's doing a great
job the restaurant is [__] beautiful
but for some
reason as I was walking in I put the
whistle in my
pocket I walk into the bar I say hello
my buy goes hey stupid I turn around I
haven't seen him since I moved here I
give him a big hug we grew up together
and as we're talking friend of mine
comes in I hug him let's get a table and
also my other buddy walks in so the four
of us are there we're waiting on one
other guy Sabatino the kid who cried
during the [__] when I had the porno
when I was 13 and he was like 10 that
guy he's back in my life and I love it
he's crazier than ever so uh he's back
in your life yeah yeah he's he just
popped back up after like couple years
you know what I'm saying things happened
anyway yeah
anyway anyway you brought the whistle I
brought the whistle was sitting
there and the owner a sweet sweetheart
of a guy and my friend the manager are
eating dinner with
us and cracking jokes at the table
laughing now my friends know I got a
whistle but the owner and my buddy don't
know I have a whistle and I hit the
whistle twice
they both got up at the same time and
ran because they thought the fire alarm
and got off so me and my buddies are how
and I'm like don't say nothing they sit
down again I hit them with another
whistle like eight minutes later they're
both like Jesus Christ what the [__] is
going you know I'm you're terrorizing
New Jersey huh you're terrorizing New
Jersey yeah you see like who brings a
whistle and your buddy works there
that's so [__] oh my god look I'm 60
I'm half [__] I gotta kill time you
know what I'm saying I'm just trying to
you know I'm just trying to have a good
time and keep it together that's it it's
a good birthday card if it's a whistle
[__] it so beard it what do you what do
you want me to drive around with a
[__] BB gun and shoot people at the
bus
stop no I'm really happy you on doing
that I didn't know you had to bring a
whistle around
though listen when you bring a whistle
around these times it keeps people in
check especially that whistle it's
[__] tremendous sometimes I do it my
daughter jumps up in the car she don't
even
see but anyway Lee I gotta drop this on
you what's up so me and my three buddies
sit down four buddies were talking blah
blah blah blah blah blah and also my
buddy says to me hey behind you is your
old buddy Mike boli [__] I know Mike
since I'm a kid great guy turn around
he's with his mom
she's like a hundred she still looks
good
though and Mike looks at me and I go and
he gets up ah he gives me a hug good to
see you all this [__] last time I I saw
him at a wake when I came back here and
I'm hugging him and I'm looking at this
dude and he's looking at me pointing at
me
Lee so I'm like oh
no I gotta deal with this [__] guy
he's going to want a picture just about
to sit down and eat and
order I looked a little closer at him
and I'm like holy
[__] that's my old CYO coach from the
eighth grade basketball yep his name was
Steve ruano he was my coach at St
Michaels the assistant coach was Steve
aardi holy [__] and dog we held each
other I cried
because I knew rude when my mother was
alive like I knew rubbe and I used to
always break his balls I would always
when I was playing for him I always go
because he was a cameraman he was a
young kid I was gonna say if I was
[__] 13 he had to be
1920 oh [__] okay 21 and he was already
a cameraman on Good Morning America
that's cool every time I would see him I
go dog when are you gonna get me on Good
Morning America how just I just wanted a
job in that industry I didn't know where
to start I go let me go in and carry
shiy and he would laugh and I'll never
forget when I got sober partly in 85 I
actually called him like I hadn't seen
him since like
80 which I'll get back to and uh I
called him in 85 I'm like hey rub what's
the story with that job he's like are
you going to [__] stop with this [__]
I can't just get you a job because
because I knew people who were stage
handlers over there and I knew that they
were I didn't know if there were Big
Shots over there I wasn't sure but
anyway to make a long story short he
told me he goes you didn't get on good
morning I didn't get you on Good Morning
America but you got on the stage anyway
on your own so I'm proud of you and then
we sat he had his wife with him another
couple so I didn't want to bother him
and then at one point he walked over and
he goes you know I was just thinking
about the time you and that other northb
guy robbed all the [__]
boosters do you remember that and I go
yes I do we must have taken 800 stickers
in those days we called them boosters
there were [__] stickers you stuck
them on your window that said I support
St Michael CYO or Johnny Banana's Temple
whatever the [__] it was and you sold
them I sold like 200 at my mother's bar
and then he shut it down the following
Monday at practice he's like I'm going
to close the door and make believe I
don't know who did it tonight by the
time we leave here for practice I want
the [__] uh all the stickers back so
me and the other dudes put them back if
we took 800 there was probably 600 in
there they took the loss but nobody went
to
jail that's crazy you remember you from
eighth grade and there was a Qui dude
there that used to be a little chubbier
he didn't start but when he played he
played [__]
tough and I'll never forget one night we
were Stone practicing in there on a
Monday night because we used to always
practice on a Monday night but after we
got together after we started knowing
each other we knew that some of us got
high and we'd vow to get high and then
put Visine in our eyes and your mother's
cologne and we go to practice and giggle
as [__] and one night we were high as
[__] me Louie Whitey and somebody's
going to take the ball out to throw like
somebody's gonna take the ball out like
to bounce pass to somebody right and
this kid that was a big chubbi a kid
went to steal the ball so my buddy
picked up the ball like he was gonna
throw it and homie jumped up but at the
same time his mouth was open right and
my other buddy goes look at him he
thinks it's a
meatball bust on the floor and I'm sure
he was embarrassed well I hope I don't
bump into that dude today that dude was
Frankie Winters that dude played with
[__] Brett far he [__] was a
center over there all those years that
guy was an Allstar forever a pro bowler
holy [__] to become somebody and that's
what he said he goes I can't believe out
of all the years I coach I ended up with
a [__] Center and a [__]
comedian I don't even know why I told
you that who gives a [__] it's a cool
it's cool to see like I
mean like how many years has it been
since your mom
passed 40
something I haven't seen him then he
told the story he goes the last time I
saw you he goes when I heard from you he
goes I heard from you years
later but he goes I must have saw you he
was trying to give me the date I
couldn't figure it out that night but I
know the last time he saw me and he goes
you were sweating you didn't look good
and all I could see was your eyes were
pitch black you were up to no
good so it's just cool it must be must
feel nice to like have him see like how
well you've done and just like to
remember being in eighth grade like
because that wasn't that like the last
year you did basketball like I think
like you tried make you know I went down
there
I had to go down there for something I
had to go into the middle of Union
City and I purposely went that way to
look at where Holy Rosary Academy was
for girls Berger line then you crossed
over and it was St Michaels there was a
girl I used to date that her parents own
the house there right across the street
from the
church and I remember that when I went
this
is maybe uh I got here in August
and I went up there maybe in
uh
February and I went down that street and
I was
heartbroken all that [__] was gone
except the pizza place that we went to
around the corner was still there I mean
it wasn't owned by Enzo or whatever the
name is anymore right but it was amazing
how the know now it's Obama high
school they got that they got Emerson
they got the two high schools and turned
them into one you know so whatever it's
a different [__] place right now you
know what I'm saying that's what are
your plans for the week what shows do
you have talk this week I I have two
cool things uh the next well the next
two Wednesdays I have
shows uh one in Wilbraham and a in a
barn which I think it's like a local
thing it's been [__] awesome and next
Wednesday I'm at auor rails and
Worcester but then I'm
seeing uh Dave Chappelle this week I'm
excited to see him this I'm seeing him
and he has a lot with him I'm excited to
see all of his open I've heard go he's
gonna have lunell Donell oh lunell is
gonna be there too hopefully she's been
going on this tour oh [__] that'd be
cool and that's gonna be tremendous
because Dave is very
lowkey right Dave is always Dave's
genius even since 94 the first time I
saw him at well not the first time but
the first time I saw him like in a
comedy club was at the comedy Boston
Comedy Club it was a Monday night open
mik that I wasn't they weren't gon to
put me on Jack I just went as like I
told you a spectator and I remembered
that what impressed me most about Dave
then and now he's the chief of is his
patience on
stage even though he's dying to tell you
the joke he knows he has to be
patient and that is lethal that is a
great attitude to have that you're so
confident you're material that you're
going to slow the pace
down and watch before you hit like
Israel you know what I'm saying like
they're just sitting there right now
with the tanks I don't know it's gonna
get ugly but it's the same thing that's
a that's standup comedy the standup
comedy is really an
act okay it's a person that you [__]
become okay it's somebody that you
become it's somebody who you want I mean
that's how I looked at it okay me every
day people contact me or they contact me
for podcast stuff but it's an act for me
I made it real I Incorporated my life in
there right which difficult sometimes
but I still had to push through it
because I know that was where the comedy
was that was where the real comedy was
that's where I touched you you know I
see podcast now even ours you know
listen we're just doing a checkin here
I'm not looking to [__] nothing here
I'm I enjoy doing this with you anyway I
get to see you I get to make sure you're
not eating hummus I get you know I get
to see what's going on with you we get
to
talk but
even podcasts have kind of become like
uh we're just talking
here when I did anything I did whether
it was standup the
storytelling the church or whatever I
always tried to slow you down I wanted
you to find the comedy and the pain you
know what I'm saying that I know I was
doing it at the time not really but I
felt something different from when I was
doing comedy before and going up there
and doing a a Rodney Dangerfield
impression because you were talking
earlier in the podcast about like that
night that you came back and you were
angry and you used to tell a joke like
you like to get people to piss you off
before you went on stage Absolut that
absolutely absolutely i s you know you
got to do
something to light a fire under you to
get your message out right that's what
you're trying to do you're trying to let
people know you're a funny
[__] right
so when is you
know when I'm going off with you you and
I both know it that while I'm going off
I'm [__] laughing at myself for going
off for acting how I'm doing it are you
really I didn't know that oh my God I
got into a
situation about 10 days ago that
I went old school Joey Diaz I I regret
it I feel very
bad but while I while I when I got in
the car as mad as I was I giggled about
the things that I
said they were not
rehearsed they were not
written nothing it was pure
gold I said like three things that even
I said oh my God where did I come up
with that and people have no idea if you
go to the Judy cter
workbook it says exercises to do and
there's a whole thing in there about
write about what you
hate and I when I first got that book
when I first got into comedy even when I
used to read it I would do all the other
exercises until and it took me like four
or five years I was Johnny knowt all
like every other comic Seinfeld was
popular the time so we were all trying
to be a little Seinfeld is I've said to
you that I had a suit on at first I was
trying to be Seinfeld and Lenny Clark
with a little [__]
flare but the section I like the most of
the Judy Carter book was she goes write
five things that [__] anger
you and at the time when I started doing
the exercise obviously I'm going through
a [__] custody battle so that I would
look at it the next day and go
I can't go up there at that time I
couldn't go up there and talk about a
custody battle I was not
prepared do you think you could now as a
comedian I was gonna ask you like how do
you my only concern with that would be
like being too negative because like
sometimes when I'm angry about something
it comes off as angry and like not
funny well it's not what you say it's
how you say it the the great Doug stanh
hope when I I say the great Doug Stan
hope I mean this from the bottom of my
heart the great Doug Stan hope once told
me that the reason why comedy is good is
because no matter what
happens you could go up there and talk
about it whether it's your mother
getting hit by a
car or whether it's your daughter
graduating eighth
grade you have to find the humor in
those realms
and that's why he's a great [__]
comic a lot of people going to listen to
this and go I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about Joey think about
it this is why every day you have
material this is why every day if
there's an open mic you should be down
there I don't want you to get on stage
and talk about the Jewish and the Hamas
that's not comedy that's what we're
listening to and we turn on every
[__]
Channel I want you to talk about how
this affects you
[__] you know what I'm saying if there's
a war in the Middle East you know we're
going to have a problem getting hummus
in this [__] these people gonna
have to be going back to onion dip you
know sh whatever I don't know I don't
[__] know but there's that's what's
great about comedy you could talk about
the good stuff and you could talk about
the [__] bad
stuff but I want you to talk about what
gets you angry so so here I was doing
knock knock jokes in a San Francisco
stage um honest
honest I'm doing comedy at this time I
don't
know let's clock it at 15 [__]
years which is about
right and I'm going on stage talking
about stuff that's kind of funny I'm a
feature actor I'm at the store I'm good
enough to be at the store but something
was missing and before I go on stage I
look at Brian Redban and Rogan and Eddie
and whatever if there was six of them
four of them have the same
phone and for some reason that would
piss me off to no end I don't know I'm
old school Cuban guy this had to be 15
[__] years ago you want to judge me
for this I just didn't like it it wasn't
in my Realm that four Dudes had the same
phones and they put each other and look
at their phones it drove me up a [__]
wall do you understand
me I would go up there and I would look
look at the phones and I realized when I
would look at the phones I kill that
night when I had that freethought of the
phones like two minutes before I went on
stage the guy would come up and go Joey
we're going to give him the light now
and as I was getting up getting ready
you know going and they go go knock them
dead and [__] I'm looking at the
phone like the first two nights I did
great because I got mad at the phones
you know what night I [__] destroyed
that audience and you know that I ate
dick at that place I was there if I was
there 10 years at five
shows if I
did 60 shows there I could honestly look
look everybody in the face and tell you
I ate 44 bag 45 bags of dick no San
Francisco straight up straight up I've
been bombing a Cobbs since day one I've
been bombing a cobs you understand me
they just didn't dig me and then I made
them dig me I learned how to [__] so
now when Rogan had shows up there they'
add shows I [__] come out attacking I
failed sometimes but I
experimented
but the night I literally destroyed
them was the night I actually looked at
those guys and I'm like what are you a
bunch of [__] [__] the [__] is wrong
with you guys with ring [__]
phones it's 2009 you [__] got
matching phones around
me there was an in with a computer one
night that I didn't want to close and I
broke it wait nights I had the best sets
of my life I just want to clarify
something were you just sitting in the
Green Room
and it was like silent or they were just
talking about jiujitsu or something and
started going off about phones what's
that and they like you just randomly out
of nowhere brought up the phones started
going from like zero to 100 they're
doing jumping jacks they're talking
about minerals whatever the f they're
talking about and I'm sitting there like
I gotta go up in eight minutes and these
[__] are talking about minerals
and the things on their phones that
their phones do and then they put their
phones down
and just looking at those four phones I
would have [__] deep deep anger like
I would just think about I don't know I
don't know why it just burnt me the [__]
up that they had four matching phones in
fact that was one of the things I told
Eddie Bravo when I told him Rogan was in
the CIA that [__] remember when they
had the matching phones yeah you're
[Laughter]
right
the lung feels great [__] but yeah
IED that the night I actually now there
was a bunch of guys that could turn me
into a pretzel in
that they were laughing their [__]
asses
off they were laughing their [__] ass
I'm calling them [__] look at you what's
next [__] shoes you know what the [__]
and they're dying and laughter because
they knew where it was coming from and
then one day somebody actually got mad
at me and when I got on stage Joe
explained to them it's all an
act it's all an act he's gonna come back
in that door and he's not even gonna
mention he's gonna give you a hug and
tell you he's sorry that he was [__]
with you because he wanted to get fired
up because he was going on stage I will
start anything with you just to get hot
to go on
stage at that time and I still need
I still want I don't want nobody in
there but I do because they're going to
irritate me they're either going to
bring hummus in there or olives or
they're gonna bring their grandmother in
there and I can't smoke dope there's
always something that has to irritate me
even though on any other day I would
giggle at it because I gotta get the
Spanish blood boiling to dig into I want
the people to hear what I'm really
[__] talking about the knock knock
jokes I was
writing right
that's fired up now I gota go get out of
here and do like 10 more bong hits how
long we've been on here I think it's
time [__]
up yeah we Hey listen man they are what
they are we're just having a good time
here we ain't making you no promises we
ain't telling you no lies tell them Lee
drop some on these [__] where you at
tonight tonight I'm [__] staying here
I took a lot of no where you at this
week oh this week I'm in I like I said
I'm in Wilbraham I'm sorry I don't know
more it's a barn you know what I'm
talking about if you live there it's a
cool it's like a real cool place and
then next week Wednesday the 25th and
I'm off the rails in Worcester 8 between
you and I this Bond make little money
with Jewish lightning you want to make a
statement what are you
doing I don't think you can't have you
talk about it on podcast it's a it's a
bond all you got to do is fart on the
[__] hay and that plac is going up oh
it doesn't have hey it's a nice place oh
it's a nice place all right yeah thank
God I'm done doing shows in place with
hey like I said it's always very nice to
talk to you during the weekend you know
like I said I'm not a full-time comic no
more but I always be a [__] comic and
I I like doing this with you I like week
when you hit me you know what should I
do should I send them an email no send
them a [__] joint send them a picture
of a [__] 21 year old with bottle
rockets in a [__] [__] then he
might I don't know when they're going to
call you back Lee right you know what if
you don't submit that email you're not
creating anything because sometimes you
might send me an
email for some [__] because you know
somebody told you if you work for the
clubs and all a sudden you might not
hear from me but you hear you might hear
from somebody else with the better offer
and you're going to
go how the [__] did you hear about me he
goes the guy you sent the email to Joey
Diaz he sent his package to
me so always send the package always
make the call let them tell you [__]
no always be the aggressor because in
standup comedy the first five years if
you're not the aggressor not I don't
want you standing outside their
house what I'm saying I don't want you
standing outside the house telling them
you want to rub their feet and paint
their [__] house not at all I just
want you to tell them introduce yourself
send them the package don't send them a
bottle of wine don't be a suck ass yes
if Lee tells you to call him drop Lee's
name if I tell you Lee call him drop his
name he told me to tell you to drop his
name and he'll know who you
are
if not you take your chances your goal
every week is to get on stage at this
level but your goal also is to make a
notebook and write all the people you
call and you got to make at least five
calls a day that's 25 calls a week from
Monday to Friday some people gonna hang
up on you you're gonna get a lot of
voice message you're gonna get a lot of
you know your your call has been
redirected to a voicemail that has not
been set up yet or whatever other excuse
but just that energy of you calling that
creates something trust me I was the
king of that
[__] I'm telling you this from
experience because that's like I think
it would be like a great thing to talk
about in your book is like I don't I
never want to bother anybody so like you
if you're making 25 calls a week you're
only calling one person one time a week
right like you're not calling someone
every day listen man you're looking for
work you're always looking to meet new
people rekindling all
ideas and trying to get work from people
you've worked for
before you have to balance
that I'm exaggerating at first
because I want you to think that way
that every day you got to make a call
Jack every day every day some guy's
gonna you're gonna go do an open mic
tomorrow tomorrow
night correct oh yeah of course yeah you
off stage some guys GNA come up to you
go hey man you ever playing [__]
whatever no give this guy a call I'll
call him tonight and tell him you're
[__] great you just did 20 minutes
and you crushed here he love to have you
it's 200 a hotel and they give you a
[__] Red Lobster
dinner what do you you know you're not
looking to conquer the world you're just
looking so you never know what move
you're making but again nothing happens
on the [__] couch so I'd rather go
that's why I said to you even if that
one night I want you to go watch k
going as a civilian you're not looking
for a guest set you're not looking for
nothing you want to sit in the back like
I did the privilege I did that I had
that not love other Comics
had that once I finish with my set early
on I went to The Comedy Store smoked
dope and sat in the back and I'd watch
four or five comics in a row while I
drank a water and a big [__] Coke
yeah yeah I did I snort a coat later
after my CU I used to go up at 1:00 in
the morning then but my real pleasure
down there and the real reason why I
Learned was because I'd sit there
average of four nights a week for an
hour and I made myself watch live
comedy Live Comedy so you could see
everything and I like what you do from
time to time you go see a band
every once in a while I try I try to
definitely do like a bunch of stuff I I
always watch whenever I'm lucky enough
to like open for somebody I I always
stay in the room and watch their
set all right
wellist you keep doing what you're doing
you call me during the week I got [__]
to do and people to see all right out
the wall
here I love you have a good
week and uh we'll talk in like [__]
two hours love you buddy I'll talk to
you soon I love you guys all right stay
black and now for a word from my sponsor
beautiful it's over they didn't put you
on this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I can rule the world
that's what you got to be thinking
welcome back to
[Music]
CH the checkin is brought to you by come
on manscape listen they've leveled up
and so should you they launched the
fifth generation performance package
including the all new lawnmower 5.0
Ultra listen I've already got mine
plugged in I haven't done the the honors
yet but the 5.0 features two
interchangeable blade heads with three
length setting Combs waterproofing you
get any look anywhere you can design
stuff it's all over that's it you can
have a party in that shower it's
waterproof now the performance package
5.0 also features the new weed whacker
2.0 ear and nose hair trimmer and the
crop preserver ball deodorant which is
[__] Wai you know what I'm saying
it's tremendous in the summer you'll be
rocking worlds in the winter the crop
Soo the toner and two free mystery gifts
so do me a favor Uncle Joey's giving you
20% off and pre-shipping with code Joey
J OE y manscape.com
again that 20% off in free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com your
balls have been through enough trust me
I looked at mine the other day what a
nightmare you thought Vietnam look bad
it's time to go Ultra with mans skate
support the show and get 20% off and
free shipping when you use code Joey and
now that you're all trimmed up and ready
to go Uncle Joey's going to drop it on
you with blue chew listen you never know
when you're going to to meet that
special someone if you want to make sure
you have all the confidence in bed at
the drop of a hat then you need blue Chu
listen it's the season to be jolly
bluechew is a unique online service that
delivers Ed medicine straight to your
door with the same active ingredients as
Viagra Calis litra all that stuff but at
a fraction of the cost and you save
money while having an a some sex life
and like they said they deliver right to
your door you don't need to be creeping
while they're sleeping you could take
bluechew at any time of the day and
night no matter when you need that extra
boost blue chew has you covered listen
I'm an old guy from time to time I get
urges I have desires I pop a blue Cho
it's all over but the Sho blue
Chu excuse me blue Chu is done entirely
online so you get to skip the doctor's
offices the awkward conversations and
waiting at the pharmacy it's even
shipped in a totally discreet package so
you could stock up without worrying
about the nosy neighbors or the mailman
you know what I'm saying listen blue Cho
wants to help you have a party a real
party for the holidays you know what I'm
talking about discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and then do it Jack
we got a special deal for our listeners
try blue Cho for free Joey why you
busting my chops on the Tuesday free
[__] just pay $5 shipping that's
blue.com promo code Joey to receive your
first month free visit
blue.com for more details